hallo mein name ist luca normalerweise
seht ihr mich aus dieser perspektive
wenn ich mit der webcam da vorne
aufnehmen allerdings hat mein mikrofon
nämlich dieses schöne stück hier in
bremen endgültig jetzt den geist
aufgegeben wenn ich mit diesem schönen
stückchen nämlich was aufnehme hört das
ganze ca
die mikro und ihr selbst das ist einfach
ein komplett
ich weiß dass ich schon so lange
probleme mit diesem mikrofon ab und das
liegt hauptsächlich daran dass das teil
halt wirklich fünfeinhalb jahre alt ist
das war halt einfach das mikrofon mit
dem ich angefangen zu let's play und das
ist auch immer noch der gleiche
mikrofonarm den gibt's mittlerweile gar
nicht mehr zu kaufen weil der so scheiße
ist jedenfalls hat das mikro xlr
anschluss und geht halt dadurch direkt
in das kompressor mischpult wohnen
extender draufgepackt
dsa nikolaisaal alles einfach und dann
wandert das ganze noch mal in eine
soundkarte das ist alles noch doppelt
gemoppelt weil das von fünf jahren
irgendwie noch nicht alles zusammen
gingen mittlerweile gibt es ja ultra
geile micro sie einfach nur über usb
direkt in den computer kommen zumindest
falls jetzt erstmal morgen nach dem
praktikum so um halb sieben noch in
irgendeiner offenen musikladen und tore
dann irgendeinen micro damit ich letztes
aufnehmen kann weil ich glaube dass ist
jetzt heute man zeichen gewesen dass sie
echt mal austauschen muss ich hab nichts
verändert am kompletten equipment an den
rädchen nichts nur von einem auf den
anderen tag geht's einfach wieder nicht
mehr das hatte ich schon so oft dass das
teil einfach so totale fehler hatte dann
habe ich welche knöpfchen der gedreht
rein raus gepustet
dann ging es wieder allerdings hat das
diesmal hat alles nichts gebracht und
ich denke ich kaufe jetzt einfach mal
neues ass heißt ihr werdet demnächst aus
dieser perspektive nicht mehr dieses
mikrofon ihr sehen sondern
wahrscheinlich einen anderen gelenkarm
und anderes micro halt das wollte ich
euch mit diesem video hier nur kurz
sagen das ist quasi so dass ersatz video
dann für heute morgen kommt dann wieder
minecraft video wohl unbedingt
einschalten müsst weil ich habe neun
account und dann sehen wir uns morgen
ganz normalen gaming video wieder wo ich
dann hoffentlich das neue mikrofone
schon von schon ich lass euch jetzt in
ruhe ich hoffe ihr versteht dass das
hier quasi oder heute das einzige
ist und dann sehen wir uns dann wieder